henderson police say they are responding
to an armed robbery right near the area
of green valley parkway and paseo verde
parkway victoria saha there right now
live with what we know so far
brian and denise still a very intense
situation here we're by the foothills
housing community it is gated we do know
from police that there was an armed
robbery nearby and from what residents
are telling me the thief is in one of
those houses i saw several police cars
swarm in an ambulance and a fire truck
was actually standing right where we are
right now but they also went in my
photographer and i walked along a bike
path right behind the park back there we
were able to get a glimpse of the swat
officers and them trying to get this
person out neighbors are not allowed to
go inside as you can see several of
these cars are lined up here trying to
see if they could go in and a few people
are standing in the park back there as
well again no one is allowed to go in or
come out a man who lives by the entrance
says he saw about 30 police cars
we were just actually outside last night
for a block party we're saying how nice
it was here comes swathi these things
happen no matter how nice the
neighborhood you're in originally they
were having everybody inside their
houses but they don't mind us being out
front now because it sounds like they
got
whoever they have corner
this is still a very active scene we've
only been able to see a couple of the
police cars come out and the paseo verde
library is just right here behind me i
was just told that is also unlocked and
of course stay with us as we get any new
information reporting live from
henderson victoria zaha live local now